what is up there reject nation we are
going to watch episode 2 of squid game
really enjoyed the first episode excited
to see what we got for episode 2 today
if you end up enjoying our reaction you
can go ahead and hit the like button or
the dislike doesn't matter which one
also subscribe and click the
notification bell to get notified when
our reaction for the next episode of
squid game is up and as usual full
length watch alongs where you stick with
the time code or over at our patreon
page cover a whole bunch shows over
there we're at the same tier you get the
option for both reaction highlights and
watch alongs included and also thanks to
the folks at praper for editing this now
for us three people in total are taking
turns editing this for us that's how
complicated it is to edit one of our
reactions hopefully the team gets bigger
so that way ten people can touch our
faces let's do this
[Music]
oh no
oh
wow
oh how inhumane
that's the first time i've said that
word for this show
and it won't be the one for everything
else has been fine but
[Music]
more people are alive than i thought
[Music]
when did you give birth
we're helping you
okay
[Laughter]
this is such a fascinating metaphor for
classes
yogurt
[Laughter]
oh my god they're like treat them like
animals just dangling
come on guys look at all that capital
look at all the capital
game
[Music]
oh god
those guys remember all the numbers you
know process of elimination
[Laughter]
[Music]
what happens
to the minority voters afterwards
they still have to play it's just a vote
yeah but do you get put at some kind of
disadvantage
[Music]
i demand a recount
of course not
this is a democratic process
[Music]
it's gonna say yes
oh we know all right of course gonna say
yes if it's a stupid come on
this guy you know we would
[Applause]
oh what thought that might happen
restart
whoa this is going on a way different
path than i expected it to go
whoa
oh my god lady you are the worst
thing
foreign
this is so stressful
oh my god is he a detective who's been
investigating this
either that or he was working for him
keeping an eye on all the people who
voted to go home
oh
[Laughter]
oh man what did you learn in business
i'm not spending any more money after
i'm sure
i'm voting to leave capitals
just
oh
man jesus christ this is so
heartbreaking
i can't handle this
is
oh someone he knows died on the island
there's the reason they specified that
exact book theory of desire
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Laughter]
oh god
oh
god
whoa
whoa
yeah your body hurts
oh
what
god
escalated
damn she's hot yeah dude
getting
taken care of business
i didn't mean
oh you're gonna give her a heart attack
man
oh this poor woman
it's just
she keeps getting much worse and worse
[Music]
oh buddy oh no
no is he gonna
did he already like take something
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i mean
might as well
yeah i gotta believe in second chances
[Laughter]
oh
man
ah this is so rough
[Music]
is there something more to this guy
there's got to be a thumbs up
he's the only one who's like
cheery despite circumstances
let me do what i want got a lump in my
head for christ's sake
but you're really old
you were the tie-breaking vote
certainly doesn't look pleasant she
always got a big smile on your face man
one guy that you know of
you're gonna get yourself killed man
oh
stupidest man in the world dude
oh my god
wow
so we're about to get some filipinos in
the show yeah
don't worry maybe they'll get sucked
into the game yeah
bring back a lot of money for the
philippines
okay
[Music]
he's gonna say never to come back though
hasn't he
yeah probably
oh
it just doesn't stop i know
he's gonna have no money and not be able
to see his family
because he owes me money
oh buddy
[Music]
this is the one time you could help
someone this is the only thing you have
to offer only position
jesus are they all going back i
think a lot of them are
wow there's some great match cutting
i had some great match cutting
did you at least tell the guy
does this start the games all over again
yeah probably
right like green light let's do this
i really hope he didn't notice that in
his review mirrors
[Music]
wow
so you turned off the lights
this is like bong joon ho's
pursuit of happiness
yeah
it's just like a battle royale looming
in the distance yes
don't ever let anybody tell you you
can't do something
except unless it involves money at which
point you can't do anything
uh you know it's funny like i'm
i think
most people
understand
uh the world of financial difficulties
and um
being asian myself
and knowing a lot of people in
of all spectrums of the asian
lines you know there's more than one
there's one kind of asian yeah yeah yeah
um you know
to talks about money with your parents
is such a prevalent conversation it's a
reoccurring topic
uh even with my mom especially too so
yeah i mean we grew up like financially
struggling a lot um
well going to like hyper
specific details over things just i
don't know what my family is comfortable
with being out there but needless to say
we are very much financially uh
struggling quite a bit
and one of the the top stressors of my
personal life is constantly just is uh
understanding money
and working with that in that spectrum
so it like this plays on like like i'm
sure for a lot of people too this plays
a lot on a very common stress factor in
our life and so this really just keeps i
keep getting like stressed out like
listening to all this
and then uh my dad when he was alive
like the threat of him having to lose
his foot due to diabetes and lack of
circulation and he and like his foot
looked like the way her toes looked the
mop was like my day so this was just
like oh man there's a lot of triggers in
here everything's hidden at home this is
not easy to watch
and then uh and also with like my mom
being the breadwinner like or her just
be like i can't get sick i got to keep
working i'm like jesus christ
this is just non-stop right now
uh yeah i mean obviously there's like a
godzillion or things i can't relate to
in here but there's there's enough of
the core elements i think that are still
universal for a lot of people because
we i think most of us have experienced
some form of debt
or financial difficulties at least at
some point in our lives if you haven't
lucky you
but i think most of us have
so it was interesting to like take this
episode it just went in such a different
direction because
it's it was i like it i love the choice
they made because in the first episode
they they choose to go there out of just
desperation not really knowing what
they're getting into
they're able to leave
and it is like they're they're toying
with them it's like dangling a treat in
front of an animal you know like a
desperate animal who's like stop
starving on the streets like they just
gotta eat anything and maybe that's what
that shot was
and yeah in the first episode with the
cat yeah the fish that you're offered a
lot of times people were gonna take or
not offer at all yeah yeah
um
and so it's cool that they do this
episode where they all get to go back
and you do see that
oh you it they do such a great job at
laying out
yeah they would definitely choose to go
back because they they have no choice
they they need the money you know
and it's it's terrifying when you're
that i don't understand the current i
don't know the currency of uh korea like
i don't know how that all converts they
say like two thousand dollars or
something not dollars they said yeah two
thousand like ten thousand one is yes i
couldn't tell if that's the equivalent
for us of like a 20 or something like
yeah you know so when they're saying
like 600 million i'm like what is that
some imagine it's a lot of money still
still yeah yeah yeah but i think the
inflation rates are at least higher so
yeah yeah you'll get uh amounts up in
the billions you know quicker than you
would maybe here in the states for
example oh yeah and then like the areas
of financial struggles and poverty are
way different than uh uh and harsher and
out there than uh than out here in like
[ __ ]
i mean like sure we have like a rising
homeless population there's a lot of
poor we have problems we have problems
our financial economic structure is not
the best yeah contrary to popular belief
that people will still come from other
countries in hopes of making you know
the american dream the financial
benefits and no one really you know
flees to korea or something like that
for that purpose or the philippines or
anything like that you know
uh
so
seeing this scene how they they they
flesh this all out a i was just
surprised by the choice i was like oh
[ __ ] i thought like second episode
they're going to stay i'm like obviously
they got to go back for right in some
way they got to go back and then the way
they they paint the struggles the the
it's like yes everything is linked to
money but everyone still has a different
story
of
why
they have the financial difficulties and
what the relationships are you know one
the two of them are like like with their
mother and family another one is a gang
related one another one's taking care of
the younger brother and a lot of it is
rooted other than the gangster guy a lot
of it's rooted in like love and then the
the one
i can't tell
feel free to just tell me the comments
is he like indian um or or
perhaps i mean india is part of asia but
there's also like you know he could be
from like pakistan or something like
that i wasn't i wasn't 100 sure either
tell me i'm just gonna say i don't know
so uh yeah you have him in there and i'm
like i just really care about that guy
he just seems so nice and so polite yeah
he's just so desperate you know so
uh
i i thought it was really neat that they
put pinned him in this position where
they're choosing to go back to
the terror that awaits them because they
literally have no other like one guy's
just going to go to jail another guy has
nothing to
that our main guy has nothing else to
live for and maybe he's helping out the
cop too
and like this is literally no other
choice and and that is fascinating that
really does uh
that
that i think that elevates the show in a
much more unique direction than
any other thing i've seen that like
deals with a premise along the lines
because usually it's they're thrusted
into a situation they didn't really ask
for and then here it's like nah
i got no choice and it's like those
[ __ ] people know they got no choices
yeah yeah i think that's what's so
brilliant i mean because a yeah it plays
on your expectation of like well they've
got to play more games so they're gonna
stay but what i loved about this
particular episode is yeah on the heels
of that it's a great subversion with oh
down to one vote they all decide to go
home then you think this has probably
happened before this is yeah probably
something that whoever is coordinating
and controlling this game anticipates
yeah and so yeah then to do an episode
where it is almost like you know uh the
debate of a movie
where you have every lead character
pretty much across this episode or who i
assume are the main people will be
focusing on yeah confronting
their reasons to go back like his
because also too these are desperate
people and in desperate situations it's
like you'll make so many promises
without you know all of the thought and
context and reality involved and so yeah
it made for a really natural transition
to like
we we have to go back there's just
nothing else we can do yeah you know and
so yeah it's like heart-wrenching but
also i think it's a really sophisticated
way to do that and it also helps to
enhance you know what i think is pretty
clearly you know a commentary on
i mean i don't know what south korea's
economy is like you know if it's similar
to the free market economy of america
but you know i mean it's like most
things i've seen are deal with some
form of commentary on classism yeah and
it's like you look at the game and i
mean the game is a great metaphor for
the illusion of what a lot of our
economic systems around the world are
where it's just guys if you just play by
we're giving you all the tools you need
just play by the rules and you won't get
chewed up when really it's like the
machine is way bigger and way more
insidious and way
less uh based on merit and effort alone
than they would have you believe and
then you go back out into the real world
and you see
you know the harsh reality of you know
yeah you know you just you just pay all
your bills on time and stuff and you
know you work hard and it's not
necessarily like that for everybody and
this is i'm curious to see how that
metaphor is going to keep unfolding as
they go back into the game which you
know more overtly savage than the real
world seems a lot more simplistic at
least and i will say too uh something we
haven't said at all is the acting in
this is phenomenal across the world
everyone is so it's got the best child
actors i've ever seen it's insane and
they're all located in asia all over all
korea that's where all the good child
actors are
and like everyone is so good
everyone is so good yeah and uh
i'm just so used to being enveloped and
everything we're watching that i had a
little bit of a out of body experience
and they were doing the match cutting to
all the individuals as they're
getting on the uh getting ready to go
back in the van yeah i was like damn all
these guys are [ __ ] great actors
they're all great truly and nailed the
everyone nails they feel so human and so
real
and yeah it's like even though you don't
necessarily relate to everyone's details
like you i've been
feeling for every character even the
pickpocket you know like even characters
you're initially set up to be kind of at
odds with yeah it's it's it's wrenching
and fascinating well it's like
you know you could see the path what
they do such a good job at
the turmoil of what they're going
through in the
you know is
literally it's the
they pretty much are in a position where
they're they they they might
they could die some people are literally
threatened with the actual
you know just death like the old man or
um
you know some people feel like we're
going to prison i might as well just
kill myself you know there's a lot of
things here where some people in
real life would just probably off
themselves yeah with
the kind of plight they find themselves
in you know so
i i totally
it really is just life or death it's
like
might as well go back
what i'm probably just gonna die anyways
depression
might as well there's no other option it
really does they and i i think that's
that's incredibly impressive on the show
to put you in that like you know it's
going there uh
but at the same time it it does a good
job on
just really letting you sit with it
because they go back pretty early on in
the episodes episodes like a little over
an hour and they just let you
like let it all develop into what it
develops it to or you're like yeah i get
why you're going back yeah yeah i mean
yeah i don't know what else what else
you're gonna do like what else can you
do make money other than win the lottery
yeah yeah and i love that they again in
a show that that very much has this high
concept centerpiece of the game looming
i love that the first two episodes have
been so dedicated to mostly the outside
world and the inner lives of the
characters and yeah like the first
episode lays the stage out for the game
but you know it's it's clear that it's
got way more on its mind than that and i
really do appreciate that about this
yeah all right guys
well
uh
squid game
episode two complete keep a lookout for
episode three reaction
uh
i just imagine shit's gonna get really
crazy you know i'm glad to see that the
this this especially like for uh korean
bass show
like subtitle and all to be making the
waves out here and and the you like
seems like a worldwide event yeah not
just us and uh it's cool that a show
like this which is not
like first two episodes are not trying
to engage you with violence and pulp
like there's some of that but it's
barely
and this is really uh this is like hard
slow moving mellow drama is what the
first two episodes have been you know
like crazy shit's coming
but
it's it's pretty cool to be like oh man
it's awesome to see that this this is
this is making the waves here i'm i'm
i'm happy about that yeah i really am
yeah before you know cowboy beep up and
witcher 2 and everything else comes out
start start as bleak as we can before we
kind of climb up to the front the crazy
phantoms yeah yeah totally all right
guys thanks so much for being here
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button you can check us out on patreon
we'll catch you guys soon